what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at candid truth we're gonna
talk about the truth and we're gonna get
candid with it I got my good friend
Jared bowling here because we are going
to work on a project together that is
unlike anything you've ever seen we live
in an era 2025 when AI is getting so out
of hand you can't even tell if it's real
or if it's not real and this is the
perfect time to be using this tool for
the glory of God so Jared bowling tell
us tell us what this project is because
this is really like your brain child
that you just kind of invited me on so I
want you to tell the audience what is
your idea where are you trying to go
with this and what's the final outcome G
to be I tell you what man this isn't the
first ride crazy ride that you and I
have been on that's right first ride um
is actually on little I studios's video
called not hot once if you YouTube that
it was fire we basically talked about
Hellfire and the edits were pretty fly I
think if you were to see that video you
would kind of see uh my passion for the
truth and reaching our culture today
where they're at like some really cool
Mr Beast Ed it'ss uh just things that
would really connect with our youth
today it says God will he will
thoroughly Purge his floor and gather
his wheat into the
Garner but he will burn up the chb with
a questionable fire BL
Studios what's up everybody I'm Mikey J
you are watching not hot ones the show
with hot vegan wings and even hotter
questions we're going to be talking
about the skull fill level of hell and
how hot are the people in hell dude man
I just had this crazy idea and I I knew
I was like Mikey's the one guy that I
know would be crazy enough to want to do
this as well I love it man yeah that not
hot ones was hilarious my daughter loves
that video and I've heard a lot of
people say they like it it didn't really
get the the watch that it probably
should have got because of um the
platform it was uploaded to but hold on
man hold on all right it it probably
didn't get the the views that it should
have got because of the way the
algorithm works and everything so the
idea of it was eating hot hot peppers
while talking about the topic of Hell
the truth about hell the misconceptions
about hell awesome concept I loved it
man yeah right it was uh just an
interesting way of going about and just
sharing the loving truth and you know
but uh really cool is that when we look
at scripture we know it's called The
Gospel and we know that from the very
beginning of time the Bible tells us
that the gospel or the good news was
shared by basically Mount the mouth
after the sin after the fall Before the
Flood it was just mouth the mouth of
sharing of the gospel and then
eventually after time um you know God's
people the Israelites they really
started to distance themselves from God
God found themselves in bondage to sin
but eventually these people they needed
to be re-educated they literally needed
God to write out the Ten Commandments
for them and they literally needed Moses
to begin to write the first five books
of the Bible
roughly um negative 17 BC 1700
BC and so then as we read through the
Old Testament we see the Patriarchs and
we see the prophets uh writing the
scriptures inspired by God but we get to
the point of the great Messiah and then
it continues on in the disciples we have
ending with John the Revelator but
that's not where the gospel ends because
then it's like translated into different
languages and we have people that are
wanting to translate the language of the
Holy scriptures into a more
palatable uh pie that the common person
could use and understand so you have
Martin Luther uh going through some
translations and then you also
eventually come to the point of the King
James version of like
1611 just the common person is just
dispersed but but what's interesting is
that during the medieval times
um illiteracy is a big thing and even
today illiteracy is a huge thing you
look in the 1040 window of those that
are um of like third world countries you
know is like around the equator line and
the which is where the major population
comes from the literacy rate is just you
know very low so we have the written
word which is amazing and we have uh you
know movies that have been made about it
we have um uh cartoons and many
different ways of giving the Holy
scripture to mankind even audio versions
of it has been made I hav an but yeah
bro nail it what you got
there so uh these right here we got
Daniel we got David Samson and deila
so you have to reach people where
they're at there's going to be we're
always going to be evolving how we
communicate you know we're not
communicating mouth to mouth anymore not
to say that we don't at all but the
people barely even talk to other people
don't even leave their homes anymore
like everyone is like relationships and
everything are now so virtual and
digital and text and all this stuff we
have to evolve our communication if we
want to spread the gospel to the ends of
the world before Christ comes and we're
we're living in that age where um this
information of the Gospel is easily um
able to just go around at a very low
price and even AI can be able to create
things just amazing things and we'll go
through those things as we go along in
this talk for everyone that is wondering
about this uh movie and this concept for
the longest time we've thought that
illiteracy is the reason why the gospel
is kind of like not reaching the hearts
of mankind like like it should be
because when you read the Bible you are
completely transformed to inside and out
I mean this thing just changed the worst
of the worst into the least of the least
um and so
there was a survey that was done on
Christians and only 5% of Christians
have admitted to actually reading the
scriptures 5% wow these are the
Believers like this is the crop so um
when we're looking at the Times we're
living in we're like so what is it why
why are we not able to make that
connection and I think because it's uh
meeting them where they're at yeah and I
got to admit I I have not sat down and
read the Bible cover to cover all the
way through I have probably heard 90 or
plus percent of the Bible over my
lifetime but I've heard somebody say
that um he challenged himself I'm going
to read the Bible in like four months he
wanted to read the Bible as fast as he
could to see what what he got from it
and I think it took about four months
and so somebody asked him after reading
the Bible all the way through like that
and short amount of time where you're
remembering everything like what was the
takeaway what do you think the bible
really is and he said the whole Bible is
really just a love letter to humanity
and he said that's what I get from it
you know you can read some of this stuff
you're like a what are these strange
laws and what are these beasts and all
this stuff but the whole Bible the whole
context is God's love letter to humanity
he's always striving with them if you
would just repent you will live and it's
not because he's some tyrannical
dictator that wants you to follow his
rules saying my laws are life these
other ways that you're trying to take
are leading to death and destruction and
I don't want that for you because I love
you so much you're my child you're my
bride I love you in the way that a man
loves his wife or a father loves his
child I don't want to see you get hurt
please just trust me and trust my ways
but we're stubborn and we're learning
the hard way yeah and a lot of people
are missing out on that opportunity of
uh that actual relationship with Christ
through his word and so now is a part of
that evolution of sharing the gospel to
mankind yeah because like you said it
started out with oral Traditions I'm
sure Adam and Eve were just telling Cain
and Abel we were created God gave us
this paradise and we ate the fruit and
we lost it and it was all just verbal uh
tradition and then it got pinned written
down in Scrolls and were all from all
over over the world that like we look at
the Bible we take it for granted we're
like this is just some book that
everybody has in their home but it is 66
books written by over 40 authors of all
walks of life from fishermen to Kings to
tax collectors in different parts of the
world over a thou or over 1,500 years
this is not just your ordinary book
written by somebody this is a this is
proof that this is the truth like
there's nothing the Bible's never
contradicted itself it's never been able
to be defeated to to this day in 20 I
just heard Joe Rogan talking about this
or the guest that he had on there here
we are in 2025 2024 and we're still
talking about this book that nobody can
debunk nobody can say because Satan
cannot destroy the truth but he can
twist and pervert it so we went from
oral to written down literature to radio
and then eventually television and now
we're in the internet age where you're
doing YouTube channels and everybody has
their own channel you know and you can
share the truth that way everybody's
walking around with a phone in their
pocket like we are in the information
age Jesus is coming soon and the gospel
has to reach the ends of the world I
believe it's now I believe this is the
time that the gospel is going to spread
to the ends of the world where um and
there's a lot of people that kind of
demonize artificial intelligence like
it's just this
demonic technology but this technology
can help you and I to translate the
Bible in every language that's not
demonic or to narrate the Bible or and
and we're not when we're talking about
putting this piece together you don't
have to worry about biases and all that
because it's going to be the Bible word
for word right line upon
line well and I like to see it well
exactly line upon line is very accurate
um you know and if you can't really
explain something visually then just sa
take the safe route possible right where
things might differ theologically but
you want to stay as accurate to the
scriptures as possible but we're taking
about a word for word narrated version
of the Bible and so when we look at the
um Evolution right of it of of the
Gospel this is the next part where it
can be placed into people's hands
literally in their hands and um
they can read it or excuse me they can
watch it they could read it right they
could read it right now but they ain't
no and uh they can they can watch it and
this is the crazy part like you and I
bro we come from the world and so we
know what looks good when it comes to uh
reaching on our culture where they're at
like like let's take the visuals of the
chosen not the theology let's just take
the visuals of the chosen that is very
tasty right C
well good acting all
that right the the audio is there I'm
it's it's really good and if we were to
take the AI of today and Visually check
it out it's not there yet all admit you
and I would both admit it's not there
yet but um in about a year or less it
will be yeah this technology is evolving
so rapidly that when we like we can be
messing with it and tomorrow it can be
better the next day it can be better
and it you know it takes a huge budget
for for uh let's say Marvel to make
Marvel ingame or whatever what kind of
budget did they have just to make things
300 300 million yeah $300 million do to
make 100 yeah okay to make an hour and a
half long movie where some people are
flying around and shooting lightning out
of their hands and all that that's the
type of money it takes but with AI
you're talking about the cost of a
subscription like $20 a month or $30 a
month or something and you can literally
make anything in the Bible come true you
can make Jonah be swallowed by a whale
you can make Moses part the waters and
it's visually stunning it's it's
visually captivating to where you want
to see the Bible you want to read the
Bible you want to hear the Bible because
now you can see it visually played out
and that's just where we're at you know
a lot of people will say well maybe
you're taking away people's imagination
but it's already happened to us all
we've all been so consumed by fast-paced
media that the Bible seems boring now
and that's not a slame on the Bible
that's just showing the degradation of
humanity and it's really Satan's tactic
he wants to make the Bible seem boring
so he makes his message over and over
and over with these million-dollar
budgets stunning special effects and
then the preacher gets up there or
somebody's parent opens up the Bible and
they can't they're to get away in 15
minutes and so this is something where
people you were saying read it but it it
can be read it could put the closed
caption on the bottom so even the um
hearing impaired could see visuals as
well as read the text and even that
would be
cool yeah yeah
definitely um and I think what makes it
epic is that the word becomes flesh like
literally comes to life and it draws
your attention to the Cross just like
the series of the chosen I hate to go
back and refer to it but um you know it
is what it is that's a world that that
we're living in and right now we have a
really good
opportunity um you know uh to create a
whole season the last season of The
Chosen it was like 56 58 million and it
came down to about 6 million per EP
episode but you know for them that's
like that's dirt cheapap though you know
and they're able to put out that I mean
it's good content right well good as in
like appealing to the eye and such
without getting much into like politics
and such so but when we look at what AI
can do and then under the right hands
because you just don't want random you
know b-roll pictures and videos and
looking weird you know it's got to tell
a story it takes a human mind but with
the help of AI in the correct way um it
can be able to help guide the human a
lot faster to be able to connect the
dots still has to be human operated and
such but so for the price of one episode
I believe uh that it cost to create the
chosen it would take to create um this
Bible movie idea I agree yeah man I mean
with Fiverr and all these different ways
where you can hire a team from other
parts of the world where our dollar is
worth a lot more you know you can really
get a good team going on this and create
the Bible from the Old Testament all the
way through to the New Testament with
cinematic music cinematic
visuals sound effects narration and all
of it's possible and not cheesy not
cheesy at all it's got look good and
yeah that's the thing man we have to
like demystify the whole AI thing
because because literally today I'm just
going to call it out today we premiered
a video where Aubry was having a
conversation with chat gbt and asking it
Bible tough Bible questions that
Christians disagree on and um you know
you have to kind of tell it what you
want like if you ask it is consuming
alcohol a sin it's going to say well
most Christians think that only you can
drink in moderation it's going to tell
you the majority answer but if you tell
it no stick with scripture what does the
scripture say don't give me the
Traditions I'm in and all that it's
programmed to just tell you what you're
telling where you're setting the
boundaries and so it it's just like
anything Siri if you've ever asked Siri
a question you already messed with AI if
you've asked Google a question and that
first answer that pops up that's the AI
generated answer all it's doing is
scouring the entire worldwide web for
all the information and it's condensing
it into one short answer and saying this
is what the majority of the answer is um
and so there's there's but in the chat
what I was getting to was in the chat
there was people saying you're messing
around with uh a Ouija board basically
you're messing around with a digital
Ouija board because you're talking to
Ai and so there's gonna be people if
that's true then how can we make a Bible
movie using artificial intelligence
where it's narrating it it's making the
music it's making the pictures that
eventually turn into animated visuals I
think we are actually doing a the
Christian World a disservice by not
utilizing this tool and the Christian
world is going to get set back just like
it always has when Hollywood came out
Hollywood had the best movies and
Christians had the most cheesy movies we
have to embrace the new technology to
stay up with the times and it's it's not
demonic it's just it depend it's a tool
it's how you use it the TV is not
demonic but you can put demonic things
on it or you can put preaching on it
yeah yeah exactly you know it's
definitely a thing to be good to be
cautious about yeah be intelligent but
if you're going to be intelligent about
it then you should eventually come to
the conclusion of how great of an effect
that it can have for the gospel and
that's like the main point is we're
talking about billions of souls that can
be able to be reached so quickly uh yeah
um uh we're talking about the ability to
be able to get all the video editors on
board 50 video editors of low
intelligence when it comes to video
editing like like
amateurs 50 of them six months bro it's
stun the whole movie wow chopped up
rendered everything yeah it's it's um I
mean there are some difficult things to
it you know where you want to put it in
the hands of professionals but it's just
like you know making the oldfashioned
Bible of harvesting everything that's
used for the paper and putting the water
of the reads into it and then you got
someone that paints it it's it's a
you're making the
Bible yeah and what what you're getting
at is you don't have to have like
Hollywood professionals you just have to
have creative minds that are like I have
the ideas in my mind I just can't paint
it or I don't have the makeup or
whatever it takes to make that think
come to life but now when you get on
this tool and you type out very
um detailed what you're looking for
you're going to get the picture after a
couple tries and then you put that thing
into the animation so yeah so what what
is the kind of um the process here what
I like about AI a lot is that comparing
it to traditional Hollywood is that we
don't have to have the actors with the
compromised beliefs or you know it
really hurts is seeing uh an actor in a
movie that I really like the movie that
really meant a lot to me spiritually
speaking and then like knowing that this
actor or actress um has some interesting
films that they might have been in and
they've been in afterwards it's like
wow it's kind of ruined the film for me
so to kind of have like a blanket mold
of you know Jewish people theyy this
person might have looked like Moses or
yeah yeah you know um but you know it's
all just model base instead of character
based yeah I like that you brought that
up because even like in the chosen there
were people who said every time I close
my eyes and pray now I always see that
actor that played Jesus and that guyy is
uh he openly said that he's a knight's
Templar and he talks to the dead he said
he he's talked to the dead Pope many
times and he's prayed to uh some old
preacher from the past to see if he
wanted to play that role Lonnie frisbee
so yeah you're talking about watching a
spiritualist on screen who's playing
Jesus but in this case you don't have to
worry about that because these people
are just animated they're not even real
people word for word the scripture they
would just have to just like I think the
reason why we have so much confusion
such as the brother talking about
praying to the ghosts and such on the
chosen is that we just have a a mass
group of people on planet Earth
that claim to be followers of Jesus but
haven't really spent that time in the
scriptures so they're really really
confused and Satan's just really good at
what he does and when you read through
the scriptures what you'll find out is a
lot of the things that maybe would have
tripped you up spiritually or things
that you might have been confused about
or you know talking about praying the
ghost um you know that might have been
corrected if if you would have spent
time in the in the scriptures reading it
yeah it's called necromancy in the Bible
and um and you just made me think of
something else what was
it
uh I don't remember something what you
just
said uh oh yeah you know it's necromancy
is forbidden by the in the Bible you're
not supposed to talk to the dead and
that's that's another thing is I heard
so many testimonies of people that said
you know the Bible's really kind of
boring and hard to understand but I can
just binge watch The Chosen and then you
watched the interview with the director
and he said 95% of the chosen is not
based on the Bible and it's like so
people are replacing the Bible with a
drama that's not even based on the Bible
95% not based on the Bible or you could
really illustrate the Bible word for
word so I think one thing that uh an
excuse that people have for why they
haven't read the Bible I just don't have
time you know I'm so busy every time I
get up how long how long does it take
right how long does it take to read this
out loud that's what I want to know
that's what I want to know how long well
I tell you what you know what before we
say and tell your audience how long it
takes to read this out loud you know
what I'm going to tell you about my
favorite TV series of the world yeah um
I don't know about you but when I was in
Iraq I wasted like a lot of downtime
just doing absolutely nothing and
watching TV and one thing I caught up on
was a series called friends you ever
watched it oh I used to watch it all the
time with my parents in middle school
and high school yeah right I I wasted so
much time watching it come to find out
if you were watch it from minute to
minute it's a total of 80 hours plus of
just friends just the all the series and
I've wasted my whole life two work weeks
working fulltime you know if you think
about it um and that's how long it takes
to read the Bible out loud is it just
takes 80 hours to read it out loud so
you that's pretty
convicting right uh so you're looking at
um you know less than a a movie that's
less than 90 hours long something really
doable if you look at how how many hours
people have in a week and what they do
with it and such right so I'm bad with
math if you were to watch this if you
were to watch the AI Bible movie for an
hour a day day or 90 minutes a day an
hour and a half you know most movies are
90 minutes to two hours how long would
it take you to actually get through the
whole Bible if you just dedicated one
hour one hour a day to watching the AI
Bible movie you you'd finish it in less
than 90 days
bro that's true that's like three months
three months yeah less than 90 days
that's
like a changed person right
yeah and an encounter with God the whole
world can be able to have this encounter
all at once and what's cool about it is
that it's it's it's not just a video
You're gonna throw up on
YouTube yeah but maybe we can take this
one step further I don't even think we
talked about the uh trailer that we're
going to be submitting we just went
straight into the movie didn't we yeah
it's all right maybe we can move it
around who knows so anyways um where was
I
going you're talking about it's not just
a
movie one step further yeah so if we go
one step further because it's not just
the movie but when you're let's say
you're watching the movie about Abraham
and you're like you know what and he's
taking his son up to Isaac and you're
like I want to go one step further I
want to know a little bit more about
Abraham so you hit the pause button it's
more than just a Youtube upload you hit
the pause button now it's becoming an
interactive Bible study you can follow
up more about Abraham see what his name
means uh maybe you can also see uh other
historical things that are surrounding
what you're studying currently so you
know there's like yeah now we're
sounding kind of confusing but there's
like different modes of viewing whether
it's like the Cinematic theater mode or
if it's the Bible study mode and maybe
even while you're you know during the
heads up display mode where you're in
the Bible study mode it can also offer
uh bible study tools and sermons based
on the topic that you're studying based
on your analytics that's awesome man
great idea so this is not just a Bible
movie it's an
interactive visual
Bible it's it's an
experience super cool man I love it
right I think what's what's sad is that
you know it's taken this long to get
here but we're at this moment and it's
complet doable and it's going to make a
huge impact on the world more than what
we know y I believe Jesus coming soon I
believe the world is in chaos this is
the perfect time for the Antichrist to
appear on the scene and say I am Christ
and I can fix all the problems in the
world and how many people are going to
be deceived by that scenario if they
don't understand Bible prophecy if
they're not reading the Bible and and
understand that the Antichrist will come
first before Christ appears and so
millions of Christians are going to be
like he's here we were waiting for this
time but Jesus said when they say he's
in the desert don't go when he's in the
secret chamber don't go he's coming like
lightning flashing from the East to the
West he's not even going to touch the
ground we're going to be caught up to
meet him in the air but this is how
deceptive Satan is and if he can keep us
out of the truth if he can keep us out
of the word of God then we will fall for
the counterfeit because it's such a
great deception you're talking about
supernatural Miracle working demons it
says in the Bible Bible and so this is a
vital time like right now I believe
Jesus is coming soon and what stopping
him well the gospel reaching the ends of
the world so we
could yeah we could literally be at the
Catalyst of causing Jesus to come back
sooner if we can get this out and reach
the world and we want people to be ready
we want people to not be deceived by
Satan when he appears as Christ we want
people to have their heart surrender to
Jesus when he comes so that they won't
have to face those words depart from me
I never knew you and I believe that this
could be a huge impactful tool we just
need your help like we can't do this
we're just two guys with a big dream but
we have the passion we have the heart we
have the desire we want the we have a
love of the truth we we're not going to
be trying to twist things and make it
entertaining and you know take creative
Liberty and all this stuff we want the
Bible to reach the ends of the world and
so we can only do that with your help so
there is a website and when you go to
that website you can click donate and
donate to this project to help make it
possible and it's all thanks to you guys
that it can actually come to come true
so this actually started because Jared
mentioned joining a contest the first
worldwide AI con competition basically
where they actually award you money if
you win and there's a lot of crazy
trailers out there and stuff but imagine
submitting a an AI Bible to that contest
and it actually winning so what is this
uh AI
contest D all right all right so um
we're gonna have fun Mikey uh it's the
world's largest AI film uh film
competition and we're going to be
submitting the for the trailer category
of um a two and a half minute long
trailer where we're going to show the
Bible events of the Old Testament and
New Testament and kind of bring in it
all together and they're presenting it
to a a film festival competition season
2 of project Odyssey is Here sign up now
for over $70,000 in cash prizes and
$750,000 in free
trials bro Mikey what's up did I tell
you
that all of the major Hollywood AI
sponsors like like the people that make
all of the AI softwares like Minx cing
11 Labs they're all going to be judging
this film oh wow that's amazing do this
is a cool opportunity to like really rub
shoulders with people and really you
know let people know that this concept
can actually come to life and it can be
something that everyone wants yeah man
it's like planting a seed out there and
there's gonna be a lot of different
things a lot of different trailers like
sci-fi and who knows violent like ninja
movies and all this stuff and then this
epic Bible thing comes out and they're
gonna be like what is this you know I
think that's a misconception too A lot
of people think the Bible is just some
boring book about history but dude I
mean Jonah gets swallowed by a whale
Moses parting the waters Ezekiel sees a
wheel within a wheel these crazy Visions
Beast rising out of the ocean the Bible
if you were to visualize it is such an
amazing
awesome
experience The Chosen has had really
cool opportunities to show the Miracles
of Christ and what he has done and you
know there's some things that I would
love to show of the miracles of Jesus
and what's cool is that you've got
Matthew Mark Luke and John right you've
got four different movies of showing the
gospel different angles showing the
Gospel of Jesus of you know Jesus
defending Mary I want to see that story
from uh those different uh views and
perspectives and we could be able to
visually show that that will be awesome
there's going to be some other
categories that I'm looking at you know
entering in but we'll kind of see if
that kind of happens I think right now I
think what you and I are going to do is
we're primarily going to be focusing on
getting those visuals into the timeline
and creating that story board
which no one's seen and that's topet
that is top secret um but I tell you
what all I can say is he's coming soon
all this right now is just a a dream in
our minds we're the creatives we're the
dreamers but we need your support
because we don't have the pockets for it
but if you guys feel led to give to this
if you think this is an amazing
opportunity to share the gospel to the
ends of the world with some visual
Bible that can be translated in every
language it's interactive and all these
things that we've discussed please
consider going to the website clicking
donate any amount is helpful and because
of you we can make this happen Jared
what what else can they do to really
help this
project well I tell you what you know on
this AI software is not cheap um and I
do want to be able to create some
visuals that are very nice and tasty for
this trailer and uh some things get very
complex you know especially the things
that we've worked on how difficult
things can be and what they and what
what they are also you know having a
website and going to events to help
share this eventually adds up but for
right now we're just really focused on
the GoFundMe and just raising enough
money to be able to pay this for the
software to be able to put this trailer
together all right Mikey so let's n out
for just a minute here um so we've all
made some really cool AI visuals and so
here are some that I've just kind of
made over the time uh all of them should
be mine except for maybe about three of
them but let's start off with the first
one the Bible m movie visual I don't
know this just kind of looked very cool
yes sure some things are kind of messed
up but you know you got the sunflare and
the lens and the Bible events W right
yeah this looks amazing just the thing
these are the times we're living in or
um you know
let's here there's so many choose one
okay this one's one of my favorite this
one's
beautiful look at that oh wow this is AI
like okay so did you just type text to
make this happen did you create an image
first or what so I I think this one's
the image first and then I sent it
through a a software called
Runway wow and then you know here's
another one with Christ walking out you
know whoa right it's just you know kind
of this is older stuff too but you know
it's good right yeah uh so let's go
ahead and do a little bit of
Storytelling shall we
uh so here you have the staff of Moses
hitting the
ground oh bam right and I didn't know
you had that scene man I've been say
you're trying to make that scene I I
told you that one so hard to make I
didn't I didn't show you the rest it it
it messes up it messes up watch this
watch this and then it kind of Wiggles
in there kind of you know just like
awkward yeah so this one's Mini Max
right there um so there's Moses's staff
and then here's the Epic view of Moses
and but of course because it's AI it's
gonna mess up it's not there
yet not there yet um so this one's
beautiful ancient Babylon going through
the Ishtar Gates going to like a
Marketplace
oh that is a drone shot right oh that's
and and just to get this shot would cost
who knows how much to CGI build it
CGI or go to one of these physical
locations with a drone
like wow the marketplace of Jerusalem
and look there's a there's also
something else I just thought of when
you go to these locations or do at CGI
or whatever you're talking about a lot
of schedules you're talking about for
one you're not even controlled the
weather you you're going to have to go
at the right time you're running out of
sunlight a storms coming or whatever um
maybe somebody got sick the actor got
sick you gotta postpone the shoot date
none of that right is GNA happen when
you're doing this
AI this is shot at Golden hour I mean
you have to shoot this shot at the most
specific timeline and yeah I know we're
not there yet but the it's getting close
uh it's getting so close that it's
hitting home let's put it like that I'm
a little too close to home this one is
strictly
text Jesus's chess rise and fall I
didn't even type that in it put it in
that is amazing you see him right wow
Focus the camera
Focus I mean I I've worked with
cinematographers and just to get that
shot they might would do it over and
over like oh the focus I didn't nail it
or whatever man this is
crazy and those costumes those costumes
cost that cost a lot of money to have
costumes like that that don't look
cheesy that look legit like that yeah
some of them just really hit home you
know I don't even have to tell you which
which uh part in the Bible this is right
everyone knows this one blowing in the
wind the tree back there moving in the
wind right very slow motion this is all
a lot of old
renders um sometimes AI can be a little
bit tricky and so sharing bread is
sometimes uh
difficult wow multiplied right there in
his hand ah right feeding of the 5,000
and feeding of five billion within
seconds yeah you know well you know
maybe you decide not to really share
that BR and sometimes here's a funny one
for those that are watching here's a
blooper um what that one disciple that
never really made it he some people say
he's still disappeared still standing
there right right that's hilarious a big
old guy um so you know the Bible is not
just Bible stories of Old Testament and
New Testament but it's also a Bible
prophecy in Jesus's second coming and
there's some imagery um I don't have
ownership of these ones I think these
ones are shared to the best of my belief
and you know here you got some Daniel 7
footage a wonderful way of just really
sharing what is in the
Bible um oh here's the woman on the
Beast right who is that
woman whoa right w
wow that turned out awesome yeah so um
for the movie that um that Mikey and I
are going to be making here's a kind of
like a starting spot I don't know we're
going to be still fixing it there's but
goes yeah into the Earth of planet earth
goes into the Garden of Eden I'm I'm
just letting you guys see a little bit
of it right now we can be able to uh
really tell a
story you know what story is
that right now oh is this
the I'm not sure is this the Sheep but
the an so it's supposed to be a rocks in
slow motion going into
sling oh I see so maybe like a David and
Goliath kind of thing but you never
think of him like loading that shot you
know really setting it
up we can really help set and bring the
Bible to life in ways that people
haven't really you know thought about or
been able to visually understand and
this software mostly um there's a lot of
barriers to it so it helps you to be
able to stay in those barriers and not
create visually disturbing things um
there is one more I created this for a
project of mine um for a friend
[Music]
I will Ascend above the heights of the
clouds I will be like the most
high wow okay yeah just if you were to
hire somebody to make that scene for
you that's thousands of dollars right
there
right and it can just easily be made uh
within hours now and yeah I tell you
what now's the time that we can really
Ser uh send out the gospel like never
before awesome man I love it and I
really think this is going to happen you
know we serve a big God and there's a a
saying if it's his will it's his bill I
believe he's going to provide he's been
a provider he's never let me down he's
never let you down if you guys blessed
by this episode please click a thumbs up
it really helps it get into the
algorithm and you never know your thumbs
up might help it get right into the
right person's hands and they fund the
whole thing and this can really become a
reality if you're new to this channel
click subscribe click the notification
Bell so you'll never miss another video
and we'll see you next time on candid
truth